[Music]
when the movie opens we have to sell it
to the audience with soundscapes
that was sunk in a traffic jam in Los
Angeles which likes treating the music
to make it sound like that coming up the
car it was so kind of like whenever
possible to see them on screen you know
I recorded some full you're like tapping
on the steering wheel or some other card
links that would help tight together
with the music and together you know
they built into this cacophony of sounds
and music and through it
out comes the track in some ways this
sequence should have been very easy to
work on as an editor because it was very
well planned out Damian and Lina Sangren
and full crew painstakingly designed
this to work in a very specific way when
we first put it together it worked
mechanically but emotionally it didn't
really work it really felt like it was
out of left field and this musical
number felt like it was completely from
another movie did you feel like it was
from our movie for that reason and for a
couple other reasons we actually cut the
scene out and left it on the cutting
room floor for a while
[Music]
in the canyons that'll never say friends
in the bottle on it
[Music]
you might I mean even though they were
thinking to play back you had them at
the dancers mic some of them right
because I know I use when they open the
car they open the back of the truck and
the band is in there there was some like
shouts and I usual and we I mean we
always tried to record a track of
something on this specifically was it
was kind of too hot and since they were
going to be doing flips and things we
didn't put it on any of the actors in
this sequence left the rest of the film
they were miked anytime yeah they thing
just even if it was just for a guide
track so when the truck opens that
shouting wasn't from that what I know so
when the truck opens we had a we had our
boom on oh good yeah it was really good
it has a very good woman girl lady good
oh I like the sound the fact that you
could have Fred oh come for a fan
[Music]
do you remember Justin on the day we
film that the door broke yeah Wow yes
it's actually theirs because I'm my
equipment my setup is right in front of
a blue truck the whole sequence and the
door broke the springs broke on me I
rigged it with the the effects guys
pulled it from the other side and never
near the hood of the truck
hold on the other side they hit a girl
through the truck rigged up a wire
through it yeah the doors I mean it you
know have to look effortless yeah it's
basically made up of four interlocking
pieces well actually more but that the
the original design was to have for long
choreographed shots that would join
together at very specific stitch points
some of these stitches happened on on
pans on with hands but the big picture
version of this is that the number used
to start by having a wide shot that
moves down and we meet our movie stars
the camera starts moving down a Ryan
Gosling's car and he's listening to his
music on a tape deck then the camera
continues to pan and we pan over to
Mia's car and Emma Stone is rehearsing
lines and then it pans over to a column
of cars where people are singing in
their cars then we go into the musical
number then after everyone slams their
doors in unison in this wide shot we cut
and we're back to Mia and Sebastian
that's the original order and that just
didn't work because it felt very bizarre
to be introduced to our main characters
and then move away from them to these
secondary characters what we ended up
doing is we rejiggered the pieces so
that we start with the secondary
characters we start big and then after
the number is done
all of them jump on the cars and they
slam the doors in unison then we
actually transition with the help of
visual effects we actually transition to
the first piece so what you're seeing in
the movie is you're seeing the last
piece of the puzzle stitched together to
the first what was the first piece of
the puzzle where we move closer in on
our stars so there was a way that
somatically and emotionally we found
after we reordered it it worked better
by starting wide and then moving in
closer to our characters
[Music]
we put the title on land on that
downbeat that was also very important
for us to do because that actually
separated that music number from the
rest of the film in a way that that it
almost became an overture for us it
became a teaser and the fact that it's
so different stylistically than the rest
of the film became acceptable after the
title all and then it's much easier
emotionally to then transition to moving
in closer on our characters but the
other thing is that when you don't have
a musical number like this at the
beginning it meant that the first time
people start to sing is really with the
roommates which is 15 or 20 minutes into
the movie and that's way too late to
spring that on an audience
[Music]
I did a little over 1900 piano demos oh
wow Oh at the beginning just finding the
melodies those aren't all different
melodies because I get on something you
know number number you know 35 Damian's
like I love that and then I go down that
road for a while and then we throw it
out and I move on so but we go to we
explore a lot of different melodies
there were a lot of pieces of material
and all the songs that we just went back
to the drawing board so we drew out the
song we had I just went back to the
piano and started looking for something
better and it was you know piano demo
after piano demo until I came up with
this idea one other day fun was called
traffic amongst the crew ya comin in the
crowd was called roommate amongst our
vision is additionally careful surgery
yeah that was the first one I heard and
it just gave me goosebumps I just fell
in love with the song immediately and
wonder why you may not have seen in
post-production wise here is the desk
that the the two people are sitting at
actually splits in half
so let's camera goes here so that was
part of the noise that splits in half
goes around there comes back and comes
back together while singing dinging
gasps it wasn't quiet process no funny
but that was the first thing that you
guys sent me to work on and that I heard
those that noise and I had no idea what
it was and a peek at this noise that it
is and it was great I mean you recorded
it so well and so just by going to all
the takes I was able to find little bits
that could replace the noisy part and
we're so Damien's credited as well we
shot her doing an entire take just in a
close-up Oh which never had the cameras
never moved by yeah my guess is which we
shot that with the thought like you know
could piece it in with house a great
idea
[Music]
[Music]
we were nervous like is Emma going to
want to do this and then she brought it
up without being even told she was like
you know guys I think we'd be great as
we record this live and really exactly
what we were thinking says you captured
the intimacy and you can't hear you
every smack of the lip eggs at all
that's captured in authentic yeah and
she was able to I was in the other room
playing piano as she sang and I was
letting her lead it and it allowed her
to just take the space she needed to act
it and to drive the tempo of it and to
just be really you know to have a real
genuine emotional performance that
wasn't boxed in by any pre-record that
we may have recorded months earlier
ah
[Music]
I remember just being too kind of out of
breath just watching her performance
yeah but every performance was was just
for to knock out performances that long
and she got so emotional and we hadn't
seen the song that way he'd been
rehearsing in this video just for the
for the technical aspects of learning
the notes but when we were rehearsing it
she was kind of saving herself for the
day she wasn't she wasn't getting as
emotional that she wasn't really acting
at the way she did she was kind of
waiting for to get in front of the
camera to do that so it was really kind
of a new experience seeing the songs
perform that way I know it was
incredible
Creedy
[Music]
I remember after each take going over to
video village where all the producers
were and everybody was just sort of
speechless
I found editing this musical to be very
challenging I mean you're always cutting
for some type of emotional reason and
all those factors you take into
consideration in order to make a cut now
in this case you're also taking into
consideration music you're taking into
consideration where does this picture
cut hit in the music Damien's a
perfectionist especially when it comes
to where the music hits in the picture
where the music hits on a dissolve or a
cut he's very precise he's going for a
certain type of precision so that took a
long time to get right
[Music]
[Music]
it was you know great working with
Justin Hurwitz our composer because
sometimes he could help us get out of
certain editorial jams because he could
rework a little piece of music in order
to fit I mean there's a limit to what he
could do before something maybe sounded
wrong musically but but we could
certainly hold each other's hands and
kind of collaborate and and and you know
he could do something that could help
solve a story issue and I worked with
Justin Hurwitz in a way that I've never
worked with a composer before it was
incredible you know he had a room
joining my editing room and so when
Jaime and I would be working you know we
could just get up and you know knock on
his door actually what we ended up doing
is more like something out of a TV
sitcom we didn't knock we just like open
the door and he sort of barged in and we
could say Justin can you come take a
look at the sequence you know we need
you to you know revise something here or
fix something and and he could do it or
at least he could do something that
would get us in the right direction then
I could I could I could you know work in
the pictures to sort of meet him halfway
but that was an amazing process a
process very alive and very electric
that time that's three of a tad while we
were cutting a picture
at the process I had I've never
experienced before but it was it was it
was amazing for the movie it definitely
made it an incredible experience become
the Sun every day just have all the
beautiful music and the performances you
know you work on movies and TV shows all
the time where you get to see great
performances all time but there's
definitely something special about each
time we got to do a big music number of
being dance number you can just tell
them going to be something better than
that scare you know that's because your
music amazing yeah joined come work out
we get today
[Music]
you